this is also from daly wire says former
nba star dwyane wade told cnn that he
fears for his transgender child ziya
and disagrees with legislation that
would make gender affirming procedures
on children illegal
now dwyane wade is married to gabrielle
union
who is uh a hollywood actress
and they have it was a okay this is this
is a boy
who at a very young age they declared is
is actually a girl
um and like so many of these parents
you know it's bad enough that they're
transitioning their child but also of
course they have to tell the whole world
about it
which and this is intentional that also
has the effect of
cementing that child in that identity
that false identity
because once you've taken this little
kid and doesn't know any better uh and
then and you're parading
him around to the entire world say look
this
well he can't back away from it now
you've made him into a
into an activist
you've made him into a leader of a
movement
anyway here he is on cnn
talking a little bit about this about
his his fears you know as as the parent
of a quote trans child he's deeply
afraid let's find out why
i mean just overnight louisiana enacted
an anti-trans sports ban it's not the
first state to do so the governor there
um called it discriminatory distressing
and i wonder what your reaction is in
your message to lawmakers in states
where these bans are
are happening you know you're you you
guys are going through this in your own
family and i wonder what you think yeah
i
to me it's a it's a
it's a joke i mean this is our life we
live this
and so when you out there making rules
and if you're not experiencing this if
you're not living this and you're just
out there signing away and making laws
that's not right that's a joke like come
and live come and live a day in my world
with my daughter come and see how it is
to walk through this world as as her
right like
like i i just think like we losing we
losing
our humane like we we're losing our the
human side of us
um and it's is is as sad as it is it's
it's blessed as my daughter is to have
parents who who can support her i'm
still afraid every moment she leaves our
house and not just because of gun gun
violence but because of the way that
people perceive her
in this world right
yeah well dwayne
you know we we can't really walk in the
shoes of of your daughter
or understand what it's like to be your
daughter
because your daughter doesn't exist
that's not your daughter
that's your son
okay that's a boy
and
he has you know something else and this
is something that uh
scott nugent said in our film what is a
woman
that i thought was
like everything else in that interview
is very well put and very powerful
she said that you you don't have the
right to do this you do not have the
right to do this to your child you do
not have the right to transition your
child you don't have that right
you don't have that right
okay you don't have the right to make
that decision for your child
and don't sit here and tell me that your
child made that decision because your
child did not
children can't make decisions like that
they can't consent to that
they literally cannot
they don't have the ability to do it
which is why i'm pretty sure
that if your
son
wanted to
well you mentioned gun violence
should he be allowed to go buy a gun
at this age
should it be legal for him to go buy a
gun oh no why not
okay why shouldn't 12 year olds be
allowed to buy guns explain to me
explain to me why 12 year old can't buy
a gun
see you can't explain it
you cannot explain it without without
saying something about how about their
their lack of psychological
and neurological development
okay whatever explanation you get for
why 12 year olds shouldn't be allowed to
buy guns it's going to have something to
do with the fact that they're not fully
developed in their brains
uh they can't be trusted they're they're
immature they're reckless they don't
think far enough into the future
that's your answer right that's your
reason
[Music]
yeah well that's also why they can't
choose our engenders of course
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content
you